mine
[Music]
perhaps I should explain
my name is Enola Holmes I started a
detective agency
[Music]
yes might your brother be free my
brother well I have not a single case
Sherlock slatus seems to be vexing him
[Music]
hello oh my God I have those things
behind you what wait what thing the
cabinet from Irvin it's so good
thank you it took forever to deliver
though but I love it forever I waited
months
I don't know but it's worth the wait
it's so cool
um you know what else is worth the wait
me getting to sit down and talk to you
I've been waiting to talk to you for so
long congratulations you're such a
badass this movement thank you huge I
loved it I was reading that you said
that your relationship with your older
brother actually helped prepare you for
this movie and so because it's been so
much time with Henry I wanted to know in
what ways is Henry Cavill like your
older brother
uh well my gosh I'd have to say the
opposite in what ways is Charlie related
to but um Henry's an introvert so is my
brother so with Sherlock so as a
collective they're very similar people
they have very witty banter they're very
quick on their feet
um very quiet and subtle and observant
and detailed and I think that's what
makes them so layered you always want to
know more about them and so I had to
really use the the relationship and
dynamic I have with my brother to to
kind of use those same tools that I have
been given like growing up with him and
use them on Henry because Henry didn't
grow up with sisters so I had to kind of
put him in tip top shape
well you definitely did your Chemistry
pops off on screen and so many of the
scenes are just so good in this movie
The Music Hall scene is one of my
favorites and I read that you actually
wanted to go into that scene clean and
so you didn't read the script before and
I was wondering do you do that in any of
your other projects like stranger things
yeah sometimes I say I don't want to go
into a space just like film me go into
the space and see what happens
um but for this specifically yeah I just
wanted to feel really immersed and I
also wanted to feel shocked by the
surrounding of the people and
um yeah so I I did they I didn't go into
the set itself until they started
rolling camera that's so cool is there a
scene in stranger things that you
remember that you did that for
no I wouldn't say so
um
I no I wouldn't I I I'm sure there is
somewhere down there I don't know if I
can remember off the spot I can remember
I was so Nola focused right now that
strange things when people ask me I'm
literally
there's a whole nother world to me that
I have to like dig into and remember
totally totally no but that is so cool
and what else I think is really cool is
that you and anola homes are very
similar uh you know you were saying that
you were both brutally honest and you're
very dry and the more that you grow the
more this beautiful anola homes
character grows so I wanted to know
because this is the second movie what in
your personal growth are we gonna see
sort of shine through through a nola in
the second installment
well
um I think this time round we both
well specifically Enola she wants to be
taken more seriously so she starts her
own detective agency and just as you
know no one is leaving her no one is
trusting her and giving her the
opportunity she is kind of cut her
losses and she's going to move back home
and just as she does in the nick of time
a young girl needs her help and takes
her on a very big adventure and I think
that it's very it's very nice because
it's it is very much the same situation
with my career um I just needed to be
given an opportunity and just in the
nick of time stranger things did so
why are you here is it my case CRM both
seems our cases are connected
[Music]
I know you like to
like to your dog Cal on set for
emotional support so I was wondering if
Cal was on set for anola homes too and
do you lean on Cal more for a role like
this versus a more intense role like
Superman or Geral in The Witcher
um look cows cow's my he's my companion
he's my buddy uh and so it's
our our lives are intertwined now to
such a point where if he's not around it
it's it's strange if I hear someone
knock on a door and I don't hear a bark
that's that's weird to me I was like oh
something's missing
um and even though even though we do
spend
almost all our time together when it
comes to set he's never on set because
as I say things go clang or bump or
whatever I don't want him barking
halfway through a take because sometimes
dogs don't belong in in a certain scene
especially with his bark which can be it
can be um
it's it's not something you want to hear
with a hangover let's put it that way
[Laughter]
last time
we've spoken to The Rock about Black
Adam when I was talking to you about The
Witcher and The Rock just keeps saying
that the hierarchy in DC is changing and
so I wanted to know do you think the
hierarchy in DC is changing
only time will tell
this is the great thing about what we do
it's it's one of those things where we
go off the audience we go off the feed
we go off the success of stuff we go off
the feel of things and and we go after
storytelling and it's never a quick
answer and so watch this space we'll see
what happens
um it's a very exciting time for DC and
I I feel very privileged to be a part of
it well we're privileged to watch you in
that role do you do you have a personal
opinion aside from the fans like would
you like to see a change
um I I I'm all for looking for making
sure that that the storytelling is true
to the nature of what superheroes are
which is
giving people an opportunity to have a
great time watching something in the
cinema or at home hopefully in the
cinema because these are such big
bombastic movies it's great to see in
the cinema and and then lead the cinema
feeling good and not only feeling good
but feeling like they want to do good
and that's the beauty of superheroes is
that they represent the the best of us
and different degrees and different
facets of and so to leave the cinema
feeling that way I think in only one it
just it just feels amazing it feels
amazing to want to go do nice things and
then when you do the feeling you get
because
people feel great when you do nice stuff
to them and that makes you feel good and
it becomes this Perpetual cycle which
I'm sure every generation says but I I
think we need that right now and I think
it'd be really helpful so that's
that's all that I really care about uh
whatever happens as long as we end up
giving the audience that that's the key
I love it well you gave the audience a
great story
um by being Sherlock Holmes and Enola
homes too uh I read that you were so
enamored with the attention to detail on
set that during lunch breaks you didn't
even leave say you would stay on set and
you'd either like read a book so I was
wondering did you take anything from
said or did you learn it did you learn
anything
I was so enamored I stole stuff
um no I I did not take anything from Set
uh but it's did I learn anything that's
a good question I'm sure I'm sure there
was a couple of things which I was
particularly fascinated by
um
off the top of my head right now I can
remember them there's so much going on
it's tough to cast my mind back to what
was uh a year ago now
um
but the set itself was extraordinary and
yes you said it right sort of in between
with camera setups and everything no
matter how long they took it was so
wonderful that set I could sit there
quite happily and relax as long as I
wasn't in the way of the crew or
anything trying to do their jobs
um I could happily sit there and relax
and just just absorb the the
the extraordinary sort of sherlockiness
of it
and it was it was fun it was fun to
discover all these weird Contraptions
and devices which they had hidden
everywhere
right that's my new favorite adjective
sure lockiness yeah it's it's probably
the wrong way to say it but it's what
came to mind
amazing Henry always such a pleasure to
get to sit down and talk
and talk to me I fear she's tackled with
the wrong
people's like you don't belong in this
fight hot or not one thing I am good at
is fighting she likes cause in trouble
doesn't she don't be so desperate to
prove yourself anola but it's important
I know what that's like to feel alone to
be ignored no one what else cares for
these girls but I think I've made things
worse nonsense I was reading that you
actually gave Millie Bobby Brown the
freedom to experiment during takes and
because Millie Bobby Brown and Enola
Holmes are so similar I read that you
told her during one take was that more
Nola or was that more Millie I was
wondering how did you distinguish the
two and what what are the similarities
and differences between them Lord
well sometimes it's because there's
something she does it's a little too
contemporary there's one laugh that I
think is in there that I'm pretty sure
isn't a nola laugh and not a million
after the Nola laugh sometimes you know
when you are uh when she's working very
instinctively and freely sometimes she
can slip
on the whole though yeah she manages it
I mean the challenges are sometimes it's
about stance you know at the time with
the clothes we wore you you one walked
in a certain way even though she sort of
you know uh looser in her behavior use
you can't you can push that too far and
it becomes something that's not period
correct
um there is a lovely moment in the fight
in the forest where having thrown a
couple of really good Jujitsu moves she
goes yes and that is Millie having only
had an hour to learn those moves
triumphantly recording the fact that
she's Managed IT you know that is merely
um but it was so good and actually again
because as you say there's so much
parallel between the characters quite
often you can include something like
that because it feels part of her
journey you know yeah that was a really
cool tidbit thank you for sharing that
uh it's awesome I love what you have
done with this film you're a director
who you know made the actors on set
actually learn how to make matches I
love your attention to detail and and
the links that you go to bring a story
to life and because we see more of
Millie and Henry together in this film
anola and Sherlock I was wondering what
you did to Foster that relationship were
there any bonding exercises that you
made Henry and Millie do yes no I I
didn't do that in the old days when you
were setting up a TV show you used to
used to send the cast out to go bowling
that was one of the classic things
people used to do which is fun and it
works you know I would get them out and
go send them off to do things but no we
didn't do that uh they they're pros and
they didn't need that but they did spend
time together and I did introduce them
and make sure they hung out a bit
together in the same way I did that with
him and with with Millie and Louis
um they had learned a lot about each
other from working on the first film
and also the power of teasing you know
Millie teases Henry quite a lot and
that's one of the things that we do we
do to get to know each other when it's
done in kindness
so uh just a little bit of discussion
some rehearsal the thing about
rehearsals is don't necessarily mean you
need to rehearse the scene you probably
shouldn't know too much about the scene
you're going to do apart from learning
the lines but you would never know too
much about what happened to you before
that moment you need to understand what
your relationship is like and so I did
sit down and get them to talk about or
encourage them to talk about what they
thought their family life was
how uh how close they were or not as
they were children how they both felt
differently about their mother
you know some things were private and
kept between one-on-one and sometimes
you share it's uh it's a process of
building a a real and
I suppose uh yeah a kind of
three-dimensional background in
character it all helps
what a beautiful process you know and I
feel like you can definitely see that
through this film it's very exciting I
think people are gonna love seeing them
sort of Bounce and banter and tease each
other like you were saying uh this film
is a lot more dangerous and grittier and
I know that you said you you set out to
make a more gritty or dangerous version
why for the second one I was wondering
well
it was sort of inevitable because one
moment she in the first film she lives
in the country
um it was quite a rural innocent story
now it would be kind of whimsical where
a young woman of 17 alone in London in
Victorian London in the 1880s that's
gonna get gritty unless you got a lot of
money you've got to pay the rent you've
got to find somewhere to live and in
this case also what would be the point
of telling a story
that was just about the same kind of
class and background as her I wanted to
take her into a different world and the
second book The left-handed lady as well
as planting and asked the idea of a
missing young woman also explores the
East End of the time and uh the dangers
that lie there so that uh it seemed like
an obvious Next Step